اهلي وناسي وبتشرف فيكم ويمكن انا غايبك
شوي عن الاردن الفتره الاخيره بس زي ما
وعدت الاردن اني راح ارجع وراح ارجع احسن
من اول واقدر ابني الاردن واساعد ببناء
بلدي
ونغير
ونرجع على خارطه العالم النافس
يمكن
فقدنا ابطال بالايام اللي مرقت
بس انا اليوم مع ابطال جايين الابطال اللي
راح يبنوا البلد اللي راح يحسنوا البلد ما
بدي احكي كثير ايموشنز بس بدي احكي انا
زلمه رزلت اورينتد يعني شغلنا مع مع قاده
المنطقه او شغلنا يمكن بالمانيا وباستونيا
وبغيرها علمنا نكون رزلت اورينتدس وحبيت
اليوم احكي قصتي ومع قصتي كمان احكي كيف
بقدر انا اغير هاي هاي الماين تبعنا زي ما
تفضل البروف وحكى لنا ومن هون ببلش بانه
اهم رصيد لامتنا شغلتين
علمك
والفاليوس انا بتخيل ما في احلى بالدنيا
من الفاليوس موقفي صغير بحياتك بغير لك كل
اشي عم بيصير معك اليوم وانا جاي على
الكرك وقفت على شيشه بترول بترول
فنزلت فكنت بحكي مع الشخص اللي بيعمل
الكوفي جوا البتراء بحكي لي
انت من وين بقول له انا جاي من عمان فبقول
لي انا القهوه هاي علي وخلص وانا ماشي
بالطريق صرت بدي اعمل اي اشي لاي شخص
موجود بالطريق معي وانا جاي على الكرك بس
عشان حسيت القيمه اللي قدم لي اياها هذا
الشخص
الناس اللي هون شو قيامهم اذا هذا الاشي
البسيط اللي صار غير كتير شغلات شو رايكم
بالشباب اللي قاعد قدامي هون اذا كل واحد
منا قدر يغير شغله صغيره بالاردن ساعتها
راح نوصل لاردن قادر على انتاج المعرفه
واحنا اليوم كلياتنا هون عشان ننتج معرفه
بدي اورجيكم البروفايل
طبعا اوكي هذا جاي
يعرض علينا بانجازاته لا
انا جاي احكي لكم انه تنسوا كلمه مستحيل
اي دوله حطت او اي شباب حط كلمه مستحيل
قدام عينيه بخسر كثير هذا البروفايل اللي
قدامكم خليني احكي لكم شويه عن اللي
بيعملها الشخص اللي قدامكم هذا الشخص كان
مدير عام شركه باعها قبل سنتين بي 22
مليون درهم لاكبر جروب موجود بالامارات
وكانت من احسن الشركات بالامارات اللي
بتشتغل على الذكاء الاصطناعي وادوات اداره
المستقبل هذا الشخص اللي بنى ثلاث براءات
اختراع وحده منهم ادوات زائد القائد واحده
منهم شراها والشغله الثانيه اللي هي
تكنولوجي كل وحده فيهم الها قصه بدي احكي
عنهم مش عشان احكي عن حالي لا عشان
اورجيكم انه هذا البروفايل اللي عم بنبنى
او انبنى هذا شخص بلش ببريطانيا ويتر
انا بلشت حياتي ويتر بلشت حياتي انظف
لترينز بلشت حياتي صبي بنظف جاش هلا انا
مستشار لاهم شخصيات موجوده مش بس
بالميداليه يمكن بالعالم وبحكي لهم كيف
بيقدروا يحولوا بلدهم بالذكاء الاصطناعي
وادوات اداره المستقبل واعمل ما يسمى
باهم دول انتوا بتروحوا عليها بتزوروها
بالعالم ليش
عشان شغلتين وهدول الشغلتين اذا انت قدرت
تفكر فيهم تقدر تغير الكون
الفاليوس والاي والفيوتشر مانجمنتولز
هدول الكلمتين اذا قدرت تمسترهم بتقدر
تعمل فلوس بتعرفوا ايش اسهل واكثر سمه
معروفه حاليا بالعالم
تعمل فلوس
فانا الصراحه صرت استغرب لما حدا يجي يقول
لي دكتور مش ملاقين شغل
انا بدي احكي لكم عن قصه ثانيه زوج انا
رجعت عالاردن الفتره هاي لانه زوجتي مرضت
بالكانسر فحبيت اعالج زوجتي بين اهلها
وناسها
فرحت مره على مركز الحسين وقعدت شفت ناس
فالناس شو بتحكي والله يا ميمتي ماني
قادره اسلم على هالاعيال لانه ايدي ناشفه
وشعري واقع وحده ثانيه بتحكي انا مش قادره
استحي قدام الناس اطلع لانه شعري مش مش
موجود وحواجبي رايحه وحده ثالثه وواحده
رابعه وواحده خامسه طلعت الفكره براسي قلت
هنا في بزنس شو عملت فتحت ويب سايت وانا
مرتي كمان بتعاني من نفس الشيء فتحت ويب
سايت سميته كران
وتعاقدت مع الشركات عشان ابيع منتجات
لمرضى السرطان وهلا هذا الويب سايت بطلع
بالاسبوع 6000 دولار بيتم التبرع فيهم
لمرضى السرطان بالاردن
[تصفيق]
[موسيقى]
اذا قدرنا نحطهم مع بعض تبنوا احسن من هيك
بروفايل بتبطل بس مستشار لنوكيا وهواوي
وبتبطل من المستشارين اللي عم بيبنوا
اليوم بتبطل من الاشخاص اللي عمالهم
ببنيوا دبي مكان كل الكره الارضيه بتزوره
وبرضو ما بتشتغل مع كل هدول الدول انا هلا
حاليا ببني هامبرغ سمارت سيتي بلان
خلصتونيا عم بشتغل هلا كنا نحكي يمكن قبل
شوي عم نحكي ان شاء الله نقدر نعمل اشي
للاردن عم نعمل نحاول نشتغل لعمان
كل هذا الحكي بس بهدول تخيلوا شغلتين
بحياتك اذا قدرت تشتغل عليهم تقدر تبني
هذا الاشي ما بدي اطول كتير على هذا
البروفايل وبدي احكي لكم بالاشي المهم هلا
في اشي عم بتغير بالكره الارضيه
ومؤتمر الحكومات المستقبل اخر سشينز كنت
موجود فيهم كان تبعي بيحكي باشي اسمه ذا
جريت ريسبت شو يعني اذا قريت ريست صلى
1800 سنه كبشر من فكر بطريقه واحده ترشي
يعني يعني كل الاختراعات والصاروخ اللي
طلع على القمر والاشياء اللي حوالينا
والتكنولوجي هو تفكير بطريقه واحده كنا
نفكر بما يسمى
اشياء الملموسه وكنا نطور التكنولوجيا
بالاشياء الملموسه بس هلا صرنا نفكر به
اشي اسمه الديجيتال وورد
عالم الانترنت اللي انت بتشوفه بتاثر فيه
وبتحكي فيه وكل هذا الحكي
ريسنت للعالم صار يفكر بشيء اسمه
كل اشي بحياتنا لازم يكون له كوبي
فصار يهتم باشياء اسمها صار يهتم بالاي اي
صار يهتم بالبلوكتشين صار يهتم بموثوقيه
هذا الجانب الفيرشول بالعالم عشان هيك
لازم اطور قدراتي انا كشب
واقدر اشتغل على هاي المواضيع بالطريقه
الصحيحه
اللي كثير مهم
والدي دكتور طبيب فزمان بتذكر جبت له جهاز
بيعمل استتشينج للجروح بيقطب الجروح فكان
يقول لي يا زلمه روح عني انت والعابك
اليوم هذا الشخص نفسه بحكي معي تلفون
بيقول لي ممكن تعلمني اكثر عن الروابتكس
كبر مخك العالم مش الاردن البزنس مش بس
بالاردن الافكار مش بس تطبقها لانه بدك
تطبقها بالاردن طبقها بالاردن بس
اشي كتير مهم عشان تقدر تبني هذا الاشي
لازم يكون عندك هاي القدرات اللي حكينا
عنها وسميناها كامز وهاي القدرات بتتلخص
بمجموعه من الادوات لازم تبني قدراتك
كطالب فيها وحتى
كاستاذ وحتى كدكتور وحتى كمدرب وحتى
كمجتمع وبنبني بهاي الطريقه اشي منسميه
المجتمع الايجابي يمكن كنا بفريق الامارات
وعدنا التعريف بالايوبا المواطن الايجابي
زمان كان المواطن الايجابي يا اخواني اللي
بيسمع القانون وبيقطعش الاشاره حمراء
وبسوي هاي السوالف هلا بطل المواطن
الايجابي هو هذا الشخص صار المواطن
الايجابي هو الشخص القادر على تطبيق
الذكاء الاصطناعي وادوات اداره المستقبل
في الاعمال الروتينيه اللي بيقوم فيها
الشخص
فهلا باوروبا عم بيجيسو قد ايه انت مواطن
ايجابي بقديه انت عم بتطبق تكنولوجي
بطريقه صحبه اعمالك الروتينيه شو هاي
التكنولوجي التكنولوجي هاي مقسمه على ويبس
اه كل ويف الها فيتشرز كل كل ويفي بتعمل
لك ميزه تفضيليه لفكرتك بطريقه معينه
بتعمل ميزه تفضيليه لالك كشخص بطريقه
معينه نبلش بالويفل المهمه هلا بنحكي عن
اللي بالاصفر روبوت اكس بلوكتين iotيه
عملنا مشروع الحج السنه هاي
او
فالسعوديه انصدمت انه الديتال اللي جبناها
للحجاج كانت اهم
وانكمها اعلى من الحج عمليه الحج نفسه
سولفيرج والبرزنس للاكتيفيتي كان اله قيمه
اكثر من الفيزيكال بروزنس لنفس الاكتيفيتي
مهمه بالعالم كامل هذا اللي بدك توصل له
هذا اللي بدك تستخدمه هذا الاداء الشغل
الرئيسي اللي بدنا نشتغل عليه هدول
الادوات كلياتهم بيعملوا كونكشن بين
بشكل عام بالحياه شو اول اشي لازم اعمله
لازم افهم هاي الشغلات وبدي احكي عن شويه
مس
بالعالم اللي هي
مثلا اذا بدك تتعلم ذكاء اصطناعي لازم
تكون بروجرامر لا مين حكى هذا الكلام
مش لازم تكون دارس اي تي ولا تكون
بروجرامر احسن افكار بتطلع اشتغلنا قبل
فتره مع الناشونال سكيورتي الامن القومي
بالامارات وبالسعوديه واحسن افكار كانت
تطلع كانت تطلع من مكلفين ما عندهم اي تي
باك جراوند
لانه
بس الها حلول تانيه صار عنا اشياء كثير
مهمه بالعالم بتعوضنا على الشغله اللي
بعدها انه التكنولوجيا راح تاخذ شغلي هذا
الاشي مستحيل يصير الا بحاله واحده
القدرات الخاصه فيك اللي هي
الادوات كلياتها راح تشتغل مع بعضها وبدي
احكي اخر تعريف مهم بالنسبه لنا بهاي
الادوات هو الذكاء الاصطناعي بتلاقي
ملايين يمكن هلا التعريفات للذكاء
الاصطناعي بس انا بدي اختصر لكم اياه
بطريقه بسيطه اذا قدرت تخلي الاله تفكر
بس او اي شيء حواليك يفكر زي الانسان فانت
خلقت الذكاء الاصطناعي السبلازدات
اذا انا مهندس وبعمل ديزاينز وقدرت اخلي
الاله تفكر بالديزاين عني فانا بطبق الاي
اي اذا انا دكتور او ممرض وخليت اعمل
للمريض فانا خليت الاهلي تفكر فطبقت هذا
كله
عم بتشارع بطريقه فظيعه باكسبونان بيعمل
بيعمل لنا
عشان هيك انا بحكي فرص العمل بالاردن
والاقتصاد الاردني
اهم ممكن له
للوصول الى خطه استراتيجيه متسارعه هو
الذكاء الاصطناعي وادوات اداره المستقبل
اذا قدرنا نبني هاي المنظومه احنا كشباب
بالايكو سيستم تبعنا راح نقدر نوصل
لمنظومه قادره على انتاج المعرفه وتحسين
الاقتصاد بشكل عام
ما بدي ادخل كثير بالويفس بس بدي احكي لكم
شغله
العالم وين رايح بدي ابلش باخر ويف اللي
هي من 20 25 ل 20 51 بنحكي عن التكس
السايبر سكيوريتي نيوروتكولوجي نانو
تكنولوجي
اذا عم بتفكر باشي يغير لك حياتك اه وبدك
تصير واحد من المليونيريه بالعالم لازم
تفكر بهذول الادوات وكيف تدمجهم مع شغلك
بشكل عام
بصراحه
بدي اطلع من هذا الايكو سيستم واطلع
اورجيكم شغله هون اللي هو اشي عم نشتغل
عليه هلا اسمه
بطريقه خطيره عم نشتغل مع ادنوك وحده من
اكبر الشركات العالم
على توفير خطه
للاستدامه والزيرو
واي شغلات كلياتها باستخدام التكنولوجي اه
عشان نكون سابقين الشركات اللي بالعالم
هذا مش حلم هذا حقيقه
ادنى قدره السنه هاي تنزل ب 600 مليون
دولار بالسوق المحلي عشان تعمله
وكبابلتيس شوق هيك العالم عمالها بتفكر
اجا علي شخص وبحب احكي هاي القصه واحد من
قرايبي قال لي احنا بنشوفك على السي انا
انه بي بي سي وهدايا وبتطلع على تاد
وبتطلع على غير تد ومش عارف شو بدك تشغلني
قلت له انا جاهز
قلت له قال لي شو بدك تشغلني قلت له مدير
عام
بعد فتره قلت له اعمل
كانك انت مدير عام هاي الشركه عمل الويب
سايت بعدين قلت له ايش اكثر اشي بتحبه
بالعالم قال لي قطع السيارات شو حكيت له
مع شركه
ووقعنا معها وكل هذا الاشي وفتحنا له عن
طريق اشي اسمه
رخصه 200 دولار وقلت له بلش اعمل لي
ماركتينج لهذا الويب سايت بالطريقه هاي
خوارزميه بتعمل ماركتينج لحاله بعد ثلاث
اسابيع رجع علي قلت له تعال فتحنا الويب
سايت عشان نشوف قديش عامل هذا اشي بنسميه
دروب شيبنج قديش عامل 3000 دولار فقلت له
هذا راتبك الشهر هذا
هيك العالم عم تعمل مصاري
هيك العالم عم تشتغل تخيلوا خريج عم بيجيب
بثلاث كل ثلاث اسابيع 3000 دولار
بعدين شفته بعزوه قاعد بقول له شوف تشتغل
بقول لهم مدير عام قط شركه قطع سيارات مش
موضوعنا بس اللي بدنا نوصله انه العالم عم
بتغير بسرعه شو انا كطالب بدي اكون عارف
كيف بنبنى هذا عشان نوصل
اللي بنحتاجه لازم كل واحد فينا يشتغل على
تطوير قدراته الخاصه ويفهم هذا الكلام
كلياته وعشان يقدر يفهموا فيه هلا قدره
بالعالم احنا بنشتغل عليها اسمها الايدل
انترنت
او الرخصه الدوليه للذكاء الاصطناعي تقدر
تطورك بهاي القدرات بغض النظر عن تبعك
وتبني لك الكومباتج بشكل عام اللي بتدور
عليها
هذا هذا كلياته بيودينا لمحل انه العلم
سهل
الفاليوس ببنيها
بقدر ابني مستقبلي
نصيحه لكم حافظوا على قيمكم
لانه القيم
بتخلق انسان مختلف تماما
عن اي شخص ثاني وبملك ميزات كثيره وما
تخلوا الظروف تؤثر على قيامكم ثاني اشي
حافظوا على هاي البلد بالانتاج ولا اشي
بينفعكم غير الانتاج ما تستنوا حدا يحكي
لكم تعال اشتغل انت بتقدر هلا تبني شركه
بثلاث دقائق وتعمل مصاري اكثر من اي راتب
راح تاخذه سوء سلح حالك بالتكنولوجي خلي
عندك قيم والله يوفقكم وما بدي اطول عليكم
يعطيكم الف عافيه
[تصفيق]
[موسيقى]